et bonsoir je l'anachronique culture
donc en ce mercredi et oui le cirque
itinérant de bouki l'hyène s'est
installé à plaisir jusqu'au 21 octobre
nous avons assisté au spectacle rock and
roll circus et nous avons également
rencontré les nouveaux talents les
jeunes talents je peux vous dire que la
relève est assurée
amanda bouglione et la plus jeune de la
famille du cirque joseph bouglione si la
benjamine fait ses premiers pas sur la
piste du chapiteau son grand frère andré
lui maîtrise déjà le diabolo
je suis né leur cirque depuis tout petit
j'y suis mais j'ai vraiment commencé à
faire du cirque quand j'avais
dizaine d'années 10 12 ans environ moi
je préférais j'engage c'est plus amusant
c'est fait d'envoyer des choses 1 est
rattrapé qu'est ce que tu es
j'envoie des massues des bagues des
cerceaux de diabo je suis un joueur un
peu différents symptômes au mois de
septembre andré bouglione part avec un
autre artiste james meek des ti au
festival de cirque d'almaty au
kazakhstan
pour ma part j'ai jamais vraiment fait
de festival c'est
première
il ya des facteurs qui rentrent en
compte qu'il n'y en a pas dans les
spectacles habituels dont le stress
alors forcément après le premier
spectacle abba une certaine déception
normale et après bah ça s'est pas trop
mal passé en effet james mackenzie et
andré bouliane ont remporté chacun une
médaille de bronze belle surprise pour
ces jeunes artistes qui d'ordinaire
partage la vedette avec un clown des
chevaux ou des dromadaires et des tigres
au total près de 80 animaux mais très
généraliste dans la famille le dressage
des chevaux tigres et tous les animaux à
l'organisation
la création des spectacles c'est vrai
que les faux il ya
un petit piment en plus quand on est
avec eux en cage qui est donnée par le
danger la possibilité du danger c'est
une rencontre avec donc ma future épouse
à l'époque sandrine gay
j'ai ma femme à demain
qui a comme elle est arrivée chez nous
avec des tigres
on est tombé amoureux puis forcément sa
passion m'intéresse est de plus en plus
le cirque itinérant bouglione a planté
son chapiteau sur le parc du château de
plaisir il présente son spectacle rock n
roll circus jusqu'au 21 octobre
deux autres dates à retenir samedi 6 au
top pour un concert de jazz manouche
avec tchavolo schmitt puis mercredi 10
octobre pour une conférence de dressage
avec leurs époux guillaume
la famille bouglione est l'une des plus
connues en france elle possède le cirque
d'hiver de paris depuis 1934 alors on
raconte qu'à l'origine et bien sans
pions en boucle yonne était un marchand
de tissus à turin et qu'il a décidé de
tout quitter voilà de laisser tomber sa
vie tranquille confortable et
sédentaires surtout pour une cigale
dompteuse de fauves c'est ainsi qu'est
née la famille bouglione vers 1830 7830
alors dans laquelle génération
aujourd'hui la génération qui va se
produire à plaisir alors il s'agit de la
sixième génération mais c'est un petit
peu compliqué de d'y voir clair dans
l'arbre généalogique si on peut voir
voyez que c'est très grand il ya
beaucoup de noms d'oncles à son nom à la
souris mais c'est il ya beaucoup de
celle ci qu'il ya en gros ce qui nous
intéresse c'est celle de la famille donc
andré bouliane que nous avons rencontrés
à plaisir
et
voilà ben écoutez c'est formidable donc
c'est un
il tente détaillée de la généalogie de
la famille bouglione avec une histoire
qui se répète l'histoire se répète parce
que figurez-vous que son pion bouglione
dont on vient de parler le premier
google phone était tombé amoureux d'une
dresseuse de fauves et bien andré joseph
bouglione qu'on a aperçu dans le
reportage a vécu exactement la même
histoire alors au début quand on
commence le cirque en fait on est un peu
polyvalent on s'essaye à tous et
finalement autour de 15 ans on décide de
la spécialité con qu'on veut faire alors
au début lui mépriser le les deux le
domptage animaux s'étaient pas trop son
truc et finalement et bien comme son
aïeul j'envie dire il est tombé amoureux
lui aussi 2 sandrine qui elle même était
dresseuse de fauves dont il est tombé
amoureux de sa femme et aussi de ces
animaux est aujourd'hui pas le domptage
c'est sa spécialité donc il donne même
des conférences sur le rallume plaisir
le mercredi 12 octobre voilà 19 heures
donc sur le parc du château de plaisir
il nous en parle on écoute c'est parti
d'une idée que au départ les gens de
cirque communiqué mal sur le dressage ce
qui amène forcément le
le colportage d'idées reçues
et on s'est dit que finalement il
fallait communiquer l'étude allez
expliquer à notre public comment on
dresse un animal comment s'y prend comme
on crée une relation avec lui pour que
petit à petit on forme si le public à ne
pas tomber dans certains panneaux facile
tendu par certaines associations qui
militent contre nous contre la présence
des animaux dans nos cirques et ça nous
a donné l'idée de chasse donc ces
conférences où on lâche les tigres on
rentre en cage et là on prend le temps
qu'il faut pour expliquer preuve à
l'appui sur tout en montrant à l'exemple
que ce qu'on raconte c'est pas que des
mots que des mots en l'air on peut
montrer précisément preuve le plus que
ce geste là quand on le fait sur un
jeune type qui ne comprend pas on
obtient certains c'est une certaine
réaction après le très sage on déroule
une fois qu'on a réussi à attraper une
prise voyez le bout de la ficelle n'est
plus qu'à tirer dessus
on a perçu la cage vous êtes rentré dans
cette case honorifique je n'ai pas osé
en plus c'était une situation de
particulière puisque la tigresse phare
du cir qui s'appelle dina est malade
donc quand on est venu voir le numéro
était un peu courte et donc on lui
souhaite un bon rétablissement
alors il y aura aussi un concert de jazz
manouche est dernier avec tchavolo
schmitt qui se produira sous le
chapiteau samedi soir pour un concert de
jazz manouche programme complet du côté
de ce cirque bouglione du côté de
plaisir